not afraid of the moment another double  team hardened trying to swipe it away  hardening cousins face to face and we're  gonna get double technicals  we don't need that in this game right  here we don't need that right  you're going to see it here right here  okay you got him trapped and everything  now once you make that hit  he's been fouled about three times in  there before any whistle was made  so you can understand why hardin is  upset  that is much to do about nothing  let's see the technical fouls  cousins and hardin double technicals so  cousins arguing about that but he went  on and bumped him too that one if  they're going to give a double factor  well that was the second that's fine  but if you're the guy with the ball  you're not happy with that meanwhile  michael green wants a fan  i think to be